Robert B Nellore is the 37th Commandant
of the United States Marine Corps he's a
native of East Lansing Michigan he has
degrees from the University of Virginia
and Pepperdine he joined the Marines in
1975 since then he's been to the army
officer Advanced Course you'd think he
would go to the Advanced Course being
the Commandant of the Marine Corps the
Marine Corps command and Staff College
the NATO Defense College and the armed
forces Staff College
he's been the commander of Marine Forces
Command from in 2014 and 15 Central
Command 2012 to 2014 marine security
force company Panama during Operation
Just Cause that's when we went down
there and creamed Noriega he was in
Operation Iraqi Freedom is the deputy
commanding general he was director of
operations for the Joint Staff in
Washington DC he's been president of the
Marine Corps University I didn't know
that until today he and his wife Darcy
have three children one of them Brett a
graduate of our college and a football
player I will say about general Miller
that I went to barracks one with Mike
Murray one time to watch the Friday
night drill which is awesome all summer
long in Washington you should go
I bet Murray can get you a ticket and
because I'm a big cheese and because
Brett Miller went here I got invited to
the private reception and it was full of
Obama officials and I thought oh wow
yeah I guess they run the Marine Corps
too and a lot of dignitaries and the
general came out and gave a talk and he
introduced them all and I thought you
know I wonder well nevermind you can
imagine what I wondered
and then he said at the end he said in
you know the president of the best
college in America is here tonight and
he introduced me me and I was stunned
and then all of the generals there it
was like 60 stars on shoulders came
marching over to me to shake my hand and
asked me about Hillsdale College general
Bailey has been here since then and so
what does that mean that means this is a
man who says what he thinks and he has
been very brave hasn't he
please welcome Robert Nellore
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
I don't I don't give speeches so I'm
gonna ask permission from dr. Arnn to
walk around and talk to you a little bit
but to he and mr. Sajak new chairman of
the board I did I did consider the offer
you made me dr. Arnn because he thinks
so much of you seniors that he said just
take them all and enlist them in the
Marine Corps and I said yes no I'm just
kidding I had you for a second though
dinner for me this is probably not a
normal thing yesterday and today I was
presiding in giving an oath of office
commissioning about 35 officers in the
United States Navy in the United States
Marine Corps
yesterday at College Station Texas A&M
and today here at Hillsdale and I'll be
very frank to the to the seniors here
speaking to this to this audience I'm a
little bit nervous and the reality is
you're probably not going to remember a
single thing I say so I will try to
endeavor to break that likelihood but as
I thought about it you know given a
doing a commissioning and talking to
those that are going to follow a path
that I followed for the past 40 years is
something you would expect me to be able
to do the life that that I chose
actually 44 years ago almost to a day
commissioned a second lieutenant was not
my plan my plan was to do my three years
and then go out and find my fortune
elsewhere and then over time this didn't
became what I did it became what I am
and I think I speak the same for the
faculty if you become a teacher or
eventually teaching is not what you do
it's what you are but as I started to
think about it I realized as I was going
through the process and am and here
today and watching it and looking at the
faces of the the
were commissioned it this really is not
a whole lot different than a
commissioning and let me tell you why I
feel that way
those those officers now officers were
students and like you they're beginning
the next path and in their life they've
completed the rigors of an academic
institution you're going to be awarded a
degree and with that degree becomes
becomes responsibility and at those same
events the one thing I also noticed is
the parents so I believe that the great
majority you hopefully are blessed by
having somebody here to thank you
afterwards and you're gonna get your
degree and they're gonna come down and
and they're gonna look at you and
they're gonna hug you and say I'm so
proud of you and you're gonna feel good
about that and you should feel good
about that I don't want you to ever
forget how that feels to have that pride
of your parents or grandparents your
friends your brothers your sisters
whomever congratulate you on this day
but that's just a first step and I guess
I would ask the seniors we recognize the
parents I'd ask you to join me in a
round of applause for your parents and
your family they're here to support you
today
[Applause]
now your job is to go out and get a job
with health insurance so what am I going
to say to you that would be different
than what I would say to a group of
young men and women that are putting on
the uniform to defend their nation and
take on the demands of that profession I
don't really think it's any different
and I don't think it's any different
than what you've heard here while you've
been a student at Hillsdale I think the
qualities and the attributes that make
people successful I think if you talk to
mr. Sajak or all the other people that
are here the van Andals or all the
people in business and the very
successful people who rightfully and
properly support this universe of this
college there is no rocket science here
so in the Marine Corps they they tell
you to keep it in threes because people
can remember three things so let me give
you three thoughts effort matters you
wouldn't be sitting here today
getting ready to come across this podium
to receive a degree if you were not
exert if you are not able to exert
effort but that effort doesn't end today
in fact the demands of your effort are
going to be even greater there's a huge
amount of talent among you your talent
is only going to result in an
achievement if you're willing to put in
the effort and so thus far you have and
I know you'll continue to do that but
their demands on your effort as you
compete against people outside this
college and around the world are going
to require more effort the United States
is in a competition around the world
with others it will take our effort to
come out on top
the second thing there will be adversity
there may have already been adversity in
your life your parents will probably
could tell you about adversity may was
adversity that they've dealt with
somebody but there will be times in the
future when things won't go well it may
be professionally it may be personally
there will be days when you'll be
challenged but your measure
as a man or woman a virtue and character
is going to be graded on or evaluator
and how you persevere you can't quit you
can't quit
I mean the Marine Corps teaches us that
you can't quit you figure out you adapt
you overcome you persevere you figure
out a way to solve the problem and
you've got all these people that dr.
Arnn talked about friends of the college
your parents or friends your family your
fellow classmates who are gonna be there
to help you figure it out you're never
alone you're never alone so we have to
overcome we have to persevere and the
third thing is character counts
character counts and that's what this
college is really all about this college
is all about character I mean you're
smart you you're academically qualified
but I think the thing that may give you
an edge is that discussions you've had
about what's right what's wrong what's
honor
what's integrity what's virtue what is a
good man or woman speaking well what is
accountability and responsibility
so all those character traits you think
about the person in your life they may
be sitting in this room with us they may
be in the faculty here they may be
friends they put they're probably family
members coaches teachers people that
admire that you admire that inspires you
over the years to get you to this point
today and they had all those qualities
qualities they worked hard they exerted
effort they were men and women of virtue
and character they were humble they were
respectful they did everything to make
everybody else better it was never about
them I was always about the team so
character counts so that's my message
effort matters
character counts and we have to
persevere in all things that we do in
closing again I appreciate the
opportunity to be here with you today
and I congratulate you all on your
achievement and I congratulate your
families for their support because at
the end of the day when it's all said
and done they're gonna say something
about us and the first part of that
sentence has already been written it's
going to say your name your hometown and
it's going to say Hillsdale graduate and
then there's a space there's a space and
somebody's going to write something in
that space and that you own that space
so what do you want it to say this
College has given you the foundation to
fill that space in the right and proper
way and I know you're gonna take
advantage of that so make it count
make it count I'm very proud to be here
with you today again to the families
thank you for your support for your your
graduate I know they are going to need
your help in the future and I know
you'll be there for them and for all of
you that are graduating best of luck and
I wish you all well in whatever endeavor
you take on in the future thank you very
much
[Applause]
I just told the general that's one of
the best commencement speeches I ever
heard thank him very much would you come
forward general please
if you look in that area right there on
his left decorating this main is
redundant upon the recommendation of the
Faculty of Hillsdale College and with
the authority vested in me by its Board
of Trustees I confer upon general Robert
Dean Nellore the honorary degree Doctor
of public service
you